[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's important for your app
to stay up to date
in order to give the latest
social feeds,
news, and weather reports
to your users.
But in truth, syncing too often
can be the worst idea
for the performance of your application.
My name is Colt McCanlis and
there's one hard and fast rule
when it comes to syncing your
data over the network.
Do not over sync.
I mean, it's a pretty
common situation.
The user has your app active,
or maybe it was the last app they used.
And you want to make sure
that there's plenty of new data
available for them,
so they won't close your app
or let their attention wander elsewhere.
So you sync, you sync a lot.
You ping the server.
You ask for new data and bring
it down as often as you can.
But let's face it, this
is a horrible idea.
Firstly, this destroys
the user's battery,
and as we've said before,
networking is the single
biggest battery hog there is.
Not only does it drain battery
just to initialize the chip,
but then it keeps it awake for
an additional 20 to 60 seconds
after you're done with your
request, also drawing power.
In fact, you can fall into
a really bad place
where each one
of your networking requests
ends up waking up the
radio and paying this cost.
Not ideal.
Secondly, consider the
sheer volume of bits
that your app is now
responsible for requesting
on the user's phone.
For users on restricted-usage data plans
this can be a make or break crime.
I mean, one app eating up a
month's worth of bandwidth
simply because it keeps pinging
the server for new data?
Not a good idea.
And this is also a double whammy
because the slower the connection
the longer the radio stays on
to help transfer data,
meaning that you're not only
being taxed for bits on the wire,
but also draining more battery as a result.
So... OK, so syncing too often is bad.
But let's be realistic here.
Your app needs the data in
order to provide the user
with the best experience.
We can't just cut syncing
out completely, right?
And the truth is
you don't have to.
There's a few handy tricks
that you can employ
which will give the user
the same sense of functionality
but require much fewer requests.
The key to this solution is
understanding the difference
between stuff that has
to happen right now
and stuff that could be delayed.
Now, for example, if the user
takes an action
requesting that their news feed
updates right now,
well, then you pretty much
have to kick off that request.
But, really, the
second and third types
are where you can actually
start improving performance.
The requests that happen
on regular intervals
that keep things up to date
but don't need to happen
right this second.
If it's not super
important right now,
then you can be smarter
about how it's synced.
Case in point, you should really never
pull the server regularly for updates.
You're basically just
wasting bandwidth and battery
for the server to tell you
that nothing's changed.
Instead, it's better to
leverage other services,
like Google Cloud Messaging,
which will let the server signal the
app when there's new content.
This will reduce the amount
of battery churn the phone is doing
and reduce the overall number
of server responses
that you need to worry about.
Now, if there's a situation
where you simply have to sync,
then make sure that you're not
doing it on regular intervals.
Now, remember this
wastes resources.
And most of the time there won't
be new content waiting for you.
Instead, adopt a back-off
pattern based on responses.
For instance, if no
new data is available,
double the length you wait
until you check again.
And if nothing's
available the next time,
double your wait length again.
This will still allow you
to sync against the data
but will slowly back away
from higher activity
based on how frequent
the server side information is updating.
And don't forget you can
also adjust seek frequency
based on user activity.
For example, if you can detect
that the user is driving
or running or if the phone
has entered into sleep mode,
you can make a good assumption
that they won't need data
at the same rate.
On the other side, though,
if you've noticed that
the phone's been asleep for eight hours
and suddenly starts
getting moved around,
then there's a good chance
the user has just woken up,
and it might be the right time
to kick off the sync request.
And finally, don't hesitate
to adjust your sync frequency
based on the state
of the device.
Waiting for it to be plugged in
or connected to Wi-Fi to do syncing
helps keep the battery happy
while users are out and about.
And the good news is that
you can update your app
to adopt these patterns
without having to write
a massive amount of code.
GCMNetworkManager is a
Google Play services API
which helps to schedule
network-oriented tasks
and handle batching for you.
This greatly simplifies
the implementation of common patterns
such as waiting
for networking connectivity,
network retries,
and exponential backoff.
Basically, all the
good stuff you need
with one single, helpful API.
And if you're ever wondering
how your application's using the network,
make sure to check out
the Networking Traffic Tool
inside of Android Studio.
It will easily show you
the frequency of your data transfers
and the amount of data transferred
during each connection.
Of course, that's what it
all comes down to, right?
Watch some videos,
improve your app.
Make your users happier.
But you're not done yet.
That's why you need to check out
the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns content
And don't forget to join the
Google+ community as well.
So keep calm,
profile your code.
And always remember... perfmatters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]